these scenes are becoming increasingly
common in turkey's largest city
amounts worth of rain fell within hours
in Istanbul
several streets turned into rivers and
dozens of cars were washed away
officials say they received around 4 000
emergency calls and the flood waters
damaged 2 000 homes and businesses
tourists were also Swept Away by a
torrent that raged through a campsite in
the Northwestern city of Kirkland
putting up a force or on the way in
Istanbul
it's a disaster the biggest we have seen
in 20 years it may take us more than two
months to reopen our store
district is renowned for its furniture
manufacturers
these showrooms are usually teaming with
customers from all over the world
authorities estimate the cost of the
damage on this street alone is around 50
million dollars and the government says
it will compensate business owners
is not a decorative if you withstand
extreme weather caused by climate change
and residents are afraid that the worst
has yet to come Istanbul
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera